[Musique]
bonjour erri de luca et merci d'avoir
accepté ce grand entretien faut-il vous
présenter quand on aime les livres on
est forcément déjà tombé à un moment ou
un autre sur un de vos textes romans
nouvelles de la poésie aussi sommes
depuis toujours engagé engagé avec vos
mots mais pas seulement même avant l
aventure de la littérature vous avez
toujours été animé par un sens aigu de
la justice sociale que de lutte avez
vous mené lutte ouvrière luttes
écologiques lutte pour défendre la
dignité des migrants lutte aussi
peut-être contre vous même puisque vous
êtes un alpiniste chevronné vous avez
l'habitude de dépasser vos limites alors
on peut pas parler de ri les deluca sont
évoqués naples et sans évoquer l'europe
quelle est votre première identité je
dois ma première les insultes et à
naples donc je suis la politique
je suis granulats et mais ma
constitution
sentimentale mais fondement demande la
constitution sentimentale sur la
politique les sentiments de compassion
se sont
formés canap mes sentiments de colère
aussi de
et des autres
je pense qu'à rentrer c'est un sentiment
politique
il y a des sentiments comme la colère
l'indignation qui sont des sentiments de
passage on ne dure pas longtemps dans
ses sentiments mais lentement nantes ne
passe pas force à réagir et à répondre
de quelques manières pour la surmonter
pour se libérer de la honte donc c'est
un sentiment politique pour moi et
pourquoi la la honte à naples quel est
le lien entre cette cette ville où vous
avez grandi et la honte que vous avez
ressenti c'était la ville qui avait la
plus haute mortalité enfantine
des robes et donc les enfants c'est le
mot nage
étaient
des survivants
et qui n'en est même pas à l'école et
j'ai le sentiment de honte du privilège
de le parfaire mois face aux aigles
et ce sentiment que c'est un sentiment
qui m'a aussi m'a appris ma mère et ma
mère me souligner toutes les différences
et toutes les privilèges que je que
j'avais donc un sentiment de honte pour
la ville qui étaient là qui étaient sous
la
mandature
la présence de la sixième flotte des
etats-unis ça veut dire que naples était
le plus grand bordel de la méditerranée
c'est une ville complètement au fait
faire
aux milliers de militaires américains
c'est une bulle ou s'ils commettent des
crimes ils répondaient à la magistrature
de leur pays
magistrats napolitains
qui se lâche armée de moi et qui m'a
fait m'a poussé à quitter naples a 18
ans mais ça c'est vous habite toujours
aujourd'hui cette honte quelque part en
tant que moteur de votre de votre action
de votre engagement
de votre création aussi
ça ça reste vrai c'est comme un le
capacité de réagir
pour moi
par exemple dans le printemps de 99 il
est où les bombardements de
l'otan sur la ville de yougoslavie
belgrade je suis allée comme quelqu'un
qui voulait pas être dans ma lui côté de
ceux qui bombardent les villes parce que
pour moi le bombardement des villes
d'une ville et l'acte de terrorisme par
excellence
l'acte qui veut détruire un nombre
magique de vitry dans la
normalité dans l'air in illimité
quotidienne donc j'ai demandé à leurs
l'ambassade yougoslavie parce que nous
bombardons une nation sans même le cri
de guerre j'ai demandé d'aller de
l'autre côté j'ai passé des semaines à
belgrade
moi seul sous les bombardements de
l'otan je voulais être de retour côté
quelque chose de personnel qui avait
requis leur accord avec moi avec ma mère
avec sens le sens cauchemar ma mère
était bombardée pendant son adolescence
n'a prêté la vie les plus bombardés
italie
et ce en cauchemar principal était le
plus de sens de la sirène d'alarmé rien
avec lequel elle s'est réveillée toutes
les nuits des seins de sa vie pour un
moment mais il se réveiller après les 1
4 lits sans donner à nouveau donc ça
sent
le fake ont commencé à bombarder à
nouveau deux villes en europe c'était
insupportable pour moi c'était quelque
chose de personnel
de l'imprimerie première depuis que je
suis à la liberté regrette j'ai été
entendu le son de la sirène de la mairie
et je suis allé me promener dollars
c'était aussi une idée de l'europe votre
idée de l'europe qui était menacée parce
que la guerre n'avait plus lieu en
l'europe depuis depuis longtemps et là
c'était le retour de la guerre en europe
près c'est le tour de la gare lille
europe c'était dans les années 80 quand
dans la de désagrégation de la
fédération yougoslave
alors quand il y avait des six nations
qui surgissait de cette désagrégation
laisser entretenir l'une l'autre là je
suis allé
un comité venant jeu jallet comme autre
chauffeur de kombouare d2
pour dizaine de fois et là j'ai compris
l'importance d'être nombreux
c'était pas tout simplement le lait de
matériel c'était le fait de arriver dans
ces camps de
réfugiés de
et de
voir qui c'était comme attendre la
visite de quelqu'un qui vient de
l'extérieur quelqu'un qui vient
personnellement pas seulement à donner
des
dents la nourriture des médicis le fait
d'être comme l'espèce des représentants
du peuple à côté de notre peuple ça
c'est une chose très importante pour moi
j'ai compris j'ai compris là que c'était
ça la le lien qui tient ensemble c'est
notre communauté européenne
cette fraternité qui se produit dans les
moments les plus difficiles dans les
moments les plus durs quand on parle
d'union européenne de communauté
européenne ce sont des mots qu'on
utilise politiquement mais qui ont un
sens profond selon vous il y a en effet
une fraternité européenne vous le
définissez comme ça julien fraternité
européenne qui vient de se manifester ma
s'est massivement dans
la question de la guerre ou crainte de
l'invasion de l'ukraine
cela ternit tu es donc je suis très
attaché à cette trinité laïque française
de la liberté l'égalité la fraternité et
pour la liberté problème qualité on peut
se battre pour la conquérir pour la
défendre mais la fraternité on peut pas
se battre pour la fraternité qu'est ce
que c'est cette fraternité la fraternité
c'est la condition
humaine qui met les personnes qui
transforme des personnes individuelles
dans une communauté
ils se réunissent parce qu'il y avait
besoin de se
lier et pour amener quelque chose en
bout et c'est vrai côté européen et côté
ukrainien parce que aujourd'hui en
ukraine où lesdites un les individus
sont devenus un peuple sont devenus un
peuple ça c'est une chose formidable qui
se produit sous les yeux d'un jour d'un
jour à l'autre c'est une chose qui me
que j'ai souvent trouvé dans la dans d
autres situations comme dans la malle de
soupe campbell de certaines luttes
ouvrières tout à coup tout lu tout les
individus se
on les mêmes réactions lisent les mêmes
mots
il en selle une seule idée
[Musique]
donc cette fraternité c'est la force de
l'europe selon vous c'est ça notre
principale force dans ce moment oui et
c'est là la grande nouveauté pour moi
parce que ces produits une une seule
cette phrase est limité
tout de suite et se manifester tout de
suite avec le fait qu'on a été accueilli
toutes et tous les tous les réfugiés
immédiatement sans aucune restitution on
parlait de votre identité napolitaine en
début d'entretien où se situe votre
identité européenne
est-ce que vous vous sentez par exemple
européen avant d'être italien il cale
bien
dans des finitions mais je suis un
habitant de la langue italienne je suis
un italien dans la langue la langue
c'est ma patrie
mais j'ai pas un sentiment de fierté
nationale
je suis je suis fier d'eux je suis
j'habite dans la langue italienne a
dressé fallait celle que vous maîtrisez
parce que justement vu que vous êtes
cordes et beaucoup d'importance à la
langue vous avez voulu en apprendre
beaucoup d'autres le français mais vous
avez voulu apprendre aussi l'anglais
l'espagnol le russe l'hébreu et de
yiddish même pour pour faire vivre cette
langue européenne qu'on avait voulu
annuler et oui je suis appelé regarde
non et après la guerre j'ai je suis là
j'ai pu partir la première génération
qui n'a pas été prise et envoyé à se
battre contre une autre génération
d'européens déclaré annemie j'ai eu ce
privilège et pourquoi j'ai ce privilège
est touché à moi et après c'est à ceux
qui ont suivi pourquoi parce que c'est
décidé les robes qui était le continent
le plus guerrier qui avait exporté
depuis des siècles ses gains dans le
reste du monde qui avaient
les guerres mondiales sur 130 sauveteurs
avaient décidé de cesser les banques de
bannir la guerre les rucks et ça pour
moi c'est le moment où cette line à sion
conquis la décision de bannir la dette
donc je suis européen ça veut dire que
vous avez une gratitude alors par
rapport à cette europe-là énorme je
pense que l' union européenne et le
l'achèvement majeure du xxème siècle
d'achèvement on dit en français le
résultat majeur résultats majeurs de
l'histoire du 20e siècle ça veut dire
qu'on a une responsabilité aussi par
rapport à cette europe là et à ce projet
là nous en tant qu'européens longe mais
le fait est que il y à toute une
génération meinau qui est née déjà dans
cette europe donc qui va là qu'il a
encore pour les faire avancer
précisément ça passe par quoi
la fédération des fédérations et il faut
là où il faut que ce soit des états
fondateurs qui
marche dans cette direction
comme andy et l'intendance suivra non
après il y aura des états qui bouderont
c'est à l'intégrer dans une fédération
nan mais ça c'est une main c'est une
tâche titanesque la tâche est importante
est-ce que ça passe par par la culture
pensez vous aussi si on veut faire
avancer l'europe par la musique passe
pas le pas de la cuisine
parce qu'il y à toutes ces nouvelles
[Musique]
nous voilà aliments qui arrivent de tous
les deux
et qu'on découvrait qui sont laides on
est super marché
multiplication de la de la
convivialité de la table
pour vous c'est symbolise bien l'europe
si la table
c'est le ch est le format la table c'est
le plus beaux objets d'art et de notre
maison c'est le l'endroit où on s'arrête
on prend
en détachement on se repose
et
c'est l'endroit où il faut faire asseoir
les ennemis pour arriver à la conclusion
les guerre finisse tout autour d'une
table toujours lui fini surtout
redoutable ya pas mal de combats à mener
quand même encore pour que cette europe
elles vivent elles survivent on sait
qu'il ya des menaces qui pèsent très
forte sur la démocratie il ya des crises
migratoires ya la guerre on le voit en
europe aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
menaces qui pèsent sur l'europe vous
êtes malgré tout optimiste je suis
optimiste dans ce sens que l'europe
c'est une voix sont sortis on ne
reviendra pas au nationalisme et aux
nations unies ou et où et nos frontières
donc la direction et celle ce qu'ils
veulent faire les nationalistes ceux qui
veulent résister à l'europe ce sont des
sondé une
zone
non messi 20e siècle et se traîne avec
ce poids à
j'aimerais vous montrer cette photo erri
de luca
ce sont des photos qu'on voit souvent
aujourd'hui malheureusement ce sont des
photos qui qui continue de vous choquer
vous profondément comme vous les avez
sous les yeux
tu sais la l'ordre du jour pour moi
de l'europe depuis une trentaine
d'années c'est l'heure de jeu d'europe
je pense que dans
la géographie
décide
la méditerranée c'est une voix liquide
comme disait rohmer c'était pas un fossé
avec les crocodiles
une voire liquide et c'est sur cette
voie liquide s'est produit le pire
transport de toute l'histoire de
l'humanité même les esclaves voyager
mieux parce qu'ils étaient de la
marchandise à vendre eux plutôt intègre
de l'autre côté par contre ça c'est une
marchandise est là qui paie en avance le
passage est donc peut être
perdu
être pas
consigné livres et ça se passe
maintenant ça s'est passé continuent à
se passer maintenant et
j'étais sur un bateau de médecins sans
frontières
il ya quelques années j'ai passé des
semaines avec comme le pas comme
observateurs comme commun le kaki et des
jours fériés les cc je vais monter
lhimer avec des bébés
alors là mais qu'est-ce que quel est le
plus fort sentiment de protection qui
existe dans notre espèce mais le
sentiment de production du met reversant
son fils quelle force était supérieur à
la protection à cet instinct de
protection pour le faire courir le pire
danger
pour lui pour eu pour elle et pour
reprendre la vie des enfants
l'a dit le désespoir
qui est le contraire de l'espoir
l'espoir c'était quelque chose qui
prétendent être
d'attendre quelques aides qui arrive de
l'emporter ou de l'extérieur l'histoire
ne fait ne fait pas marcher et attendre
le désespoir north l'espoir pouces se
sont occupé aucune
possibilité de
l'espoir de se sauver cette situation
elle est provoquée par les peurs de
l'europe aujourd'hui
la peur de l'europe la perle à
l'indifférence
une différence que c'est un an des jeux
l'appellent les diables gardien il ya
des anges gardiens dans la ville et
aussi des diables gardien des diables
gardiens sont ceux qui ne se
seront pas se coucher
reste toujours de la garde d'un
différend sein des diables gardien qui
fait partie de notre constitution nous
tous sommes
indifférents sauf à la preuve contraire
quand il ya une preuve contraire toute
la différence
d'abord
à 10 août par rapport à un enjeu comme
celui là est ce que justement on est
plus forts comme européen selon vous
est-ce qu'on voit toutes les difficultés
de l'europe à réagir à cette situation
aujourd'hui est la question migratoire
et pourtant on se dit que l'europe
l'union européenne est une force pour
pouvoir faire face à cette situation
il demande d'avoir la possibilité de
faire face à cette situation parce qu'il
a
il a
accueilli des millions de gens craignent
un
don qu'elle a toutes les possibilités de
faire face des sites luxe midi l'auteur
on les appelle les vagues l'eau
ne sont pas des vagues mais quand on l'a
condé appelle bague on donne l'idée
qu'ils interfèrent doit se défendre des
vagues ne devra aussi des barrages et
ligue contre les vagues quand on emploie
le mot vague pour les flux migratoires
ont déjà on triche sur le vocabulaire
pour donner pour susciter des réactions
sont des fluxs et les fluxus s'il coule
pour comprendre votre idée de l'europe
reid et luca j'avais envie de vous
proposer un petit questionnaire pour
savoir comment vous envisagez l'europe
si l'europe était une personnalité
ce serait qui
qui choque
tu choques pourquoi qui fait
pour moi c'est le casque blanc car pour
moi c'est d'abord sur le plan personnel
moderne qui choque est pas une car une
vision il a toujours des visions
quichotte la division duel qui sont pas
immédiates qui sont qui sont évidents
seulement à lui mais il s'engage dans le
visible pour les visions qu'il est il se
bat toujours avec une une infériorité
numérique face au monstre qui le entre
moi et
après tous les coûts après tout les
défaites il se remet debout pour se
battre à nouveau donc je trouve que ça
sera le caractère plus que le père se
lassait le caractère de cet
open ça veut dire que vous associé au
mot europe cette force de caractère et
cet espoir aussi que ça représente si je
suis la vision parce que l'europe était
une vision les replis étaient une vision
inimaginable
avant qu'elle
se manifeste après la deuxième guerre
mondiale
est ce que je teste l'idée de l'arrêt
dès lors qu'il est plus jeune que vous
en ont suffisamment conscience les plus
jeunes comment sont les gens qui sont
nés dans cette europe pour blancs
tableur pour lui pour lui c'est une
évidence donc il n'y a rien à
imaginer doit poursuivre le chemin qui
ce qui est déjà fait
si l'europe était un paysage
un paysage eux
d'abord j'avais pensé au mont blanc
parce que c'est un sommet qui
les unissent
dix nations au centre ville on sait
puis vous aimez la montagne donc ça
semblait si logique
et puis après vous nous avez parlé
d'enfer
vous nous avez dit peut-être qu'en phare
ce serait une bonne image pour
pour symboliser l'europe lampe à huile
et le phare parce qu'une
il donne une lumière pour que l'impôt dû
sur bide et des bateaux qui ce qui se
trouve
près de la côte il est là on le voit est
là et mais qui a aussi une lumière
intermittente
c'est pas comme une étoile il ya une
lumière internet elle rompt pas cette
intermittence dans son émission de
lumière si l'europe était un tableau
en tableau j'ai pensé dans l' école de
tels risques dans les chambres du
vatican
de la signature avec la représentation
des grands philosophes notamment de
l'école est énorme
ni astrologue
astronome mathématicien
quelque part
toute cette
intelligence cette culture qui s'est
manifesté j'ai concentré dans la dans
l'école d'athènes de la file et l'europe
c'est ça aussi précisément c'est ce
socle de connaissances et de savoirs
c'est une
c'est une assemblée de d'une pensée de
penser de la parole aussi de
personnes qui découvrent les lois de
l'univers
c'est cette soif de connaissance cette
curiosité aussi
et européennes pour moi
si on parlait d'un plat à présent
puisque vous nous avez dit que c'est
peut-être la table qui qui était la plus
importante en europe si on parlait d'un
plaqué ce qu'on mettrait comme comme
plat sur cette table européenne je pense
que c'est une une un gâteau qui s'est
formée au centre d'europe et qui a été
créé par un
garçon de 16 ans
monsieur france ça car je suis pas
gourmand jeu je cherche je suis pas de
la tarte à la fin à la fin du repas mais
c'est une chose qui fait sourire quand
on se met facilement à la tasse wakata
le sag lte est un gâteau n'importe
lequel aussi à la fin du repas on sourit
si le fait que ce soit est ceci au
plaisir à ses écrits que ça me plaisait
partager c'est un principe qui qui fait
monter des solides
si l'europe était une musique s'il
fallait choisir en hymne pour remplacer
l'aude à la joie de beethoven
bon le retour de robben
qui évoque cette musique pour vous
[Musique]
le bassin de 2
de danse et de familiarité c'est humain
c'est une logique qui fait venir envie
de danser moi même à moi que je ne sais
pas danser alors je le fais avec les pis
je suis je suis la musique avec lui mais
c'est la montée en puissance ceux ci qui
vous intéresse si je comprends bien
aussi parce que cela monte du nain de la
fête quelque part ça se répète 1 parce
que c'est ça aussi l'histoire elle seule
elle se répète mais ça peut aller de
plus en plus fort ça peut nous emmener
loin c'est ça l'idée
une dernière question est raide et
locales
cette europe aujourd'hui si vous deviez
la définir en deux trois mots
par rapport aux espoirs que la manière
dont vous vous projetez vous en tant
qu'européen dans les années qui viennent
c'est toujours la question de la
fraternité pour moi
[Musique]
le chantier
cette fraternité qui se renouvelle dans
cette guerre à côté de lokeren de l'oqai
rinne c'est une
nouvelle fondation de la nôtre
consistance ou mais une politique
l'europe existe
maintenant
merci beaucoup pour cet entretien on va
se quitter avec le boléro de ravel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]